ohne witz das ist der dümmste trend auf
youtube sind dem ich youtube keine
stiftung herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video und leute es ist wieder
soweit youtube deutschland zum einen
hängen gebliebenen trend reiche und
fassbar wirklich nach baden nach dem 24
stunden videos gibt es jetzt schon
wieder eine sache die aus amerika
herüber geschwappt ist und deutschland
momentan komplett vergiftet und das ist
ja auch dem typisch von gesehen machen
niemals nacht um 3 blablabla videos aus
dem englischen to know that free m
also 3 uhr morgens der trend ist eins zu
eins auf deutschland über die schwarz-
und er geht am wachsen und knapp 800
schimmelbefall bereitet er sich
ausmachen gucken genau warum ich glaube
handelt und bewerten das einfach mal auf
einer skala und ein drittel komplett
hängen geblieben wie gesagt ich komme
aus den vereinigten staaten wenn wir
jetzt einfach mal hier reinschauen
gegeben eine nette familie wandert los
hier top vier wochen in amerika so what
makes the tree mbj max flach ins lange
eck und das umso kennel club berlin
offensichtlich beide zehn jahre alt oder
review sie ist wirklich 11 oder sonos
play minecraft pocket edition sbm
winning to fit bin
und das klappt auch in deutschland leute
es ist wunderbar man kann sich wirklich
drauf verlassen und das ist wirklich ein
youtube gewährte leute wenn irgendwann
der youtube moses in der gesetze tafel
vom berg herunter trägt leute da besteht
auf die der tafel auf jeden fall unter
den ersten drei wenn in amerika
irgendeinen scheiß trend gibt der viele
klicks bringt kommt der garantiert auch
nach deutschland in deutschland
natürlich nicht etwa sondern drei uhr
nachts challenge perfekt haben wir
direkt schon und lassen so wie jetzt wie
machen niemals drei uhr nachts eine
basta challenge rebecca romijn eigene
tolerant québec gering da noch mitmacht
sprich niemals und 3 und nachdem wir
drei und acht auf gar keinen fall eine
schule anrufen 3 und 8 auf gar keinen
fall eine schule anrufen nochmals
rebecca ring um mein gott 13 millionen
aufrufe nach wird
absolut um 3 uhr anrufen geil
eine minute und nicht angerufen die
daten noch eine minute leute ich würde
an dieser stelle auf jeden fall meinen
link namen darauf verwetten dazu können
90 prozent aller drei und acht stellen
sind natürlich auch nicht mit 308
gedreht werden die leute schalten
einfach auf ihrem iphone oder die
automatische uhrzeit ausstellen halt 3
und 8 1 zum beispiel jetzt 17 uhr 43 und
jetzt nach mein gott was passiert mit
den drei besten video aufnehmen 1 3 uhr
morgens anrufen schule erkennt leute wer
hat mich auch unter dem kontakt schule
ich fragte ihn von seiner schule
eingespeichert wie schon die schule
jetzt zuletzt auch keine person die man
einfach so anrufen die schulen
sekretariat mit hunderten haushalten
werden jetzt genau man das den unfassbar
es gilt niemand dran wenn man seinen
besten freund anruft die man vorher
unter schule eingespeichert hat wundert
irgendjemanden aber ich mach das nochmal
also es ist noch drei uhr
[Musik]
nein ein wirklich kaufen gleich nein
hallo hallo ich meine nein also entweder
leute ich vollgas braucht rein weil alle
am ende auflösen und joghurt oder die
verkaufen die menschenrechte du nicht du
hast einfach deinen besten kumpel deine
beste freundin angerufen
denn vorher im adressbuch in schule
umbenannt und russland einfach an und
dann geht ein kumpel dran wahrscheinlich
noch mit 19 17 uhr in bottrop
kirchhellen mitten in deutschland und
ich war zum 3 nach dreimal anrufen oder
china thema grad normal und diese
geräusche das hätten sich in ernste an
als würde jemand irgendwie weine auch
bittere einbauen man wie schwer das
macht mich so hattest dich nein nein wir
können im jahr zwei vertreter in
deutschland nicht an der stelle sein
dass man ernsthaft denkt dass youtube zu
wort so hängen geblieben sind dass sie
sohn keinen glauben bitte leute ich
appelliere eure vernunft bitte
hoffentlich lässt sich das am ende auf
bitte lieber gott lass ich am ende auf
lösen aber wartet auf jeden fall nicht
nach leute um drei uhr morgens
irgendwelche nummern anzurufen wolle so
machte sich würde video wird mich auch
nicht während natürlich aufgelöst leute
die menschen am ende bis ist vorbei
einfach das wort stellt euch vor aliens
von jetzt gerade auch die erde auf der
suche nach zivilisation ok intelligentem
leben und wehen 3 und 8 video von
halloween mit 1,3 millionen aufgerufen
61.000 und merken dass die gute wirklich
glaubt dass ihre zuschauer ihr diese
geschichte abnehmen man kann eigentlich
übernehmen die einfach mal der freemont
rebecca ringst noch einige andere
vertreter dieses tollen job islam ist zb
träsch ich hätte auch wenn ich nachts um
14 uhr in darmstadt bensheim in meinem
kinderzimmer sitze und ein video drehen
passiert eigentlich sagen alle wenn du
das um drei uhr nachts macht passiert im
körper
es könnte gar nicht ernst meinen oder
können
die schlimme zeit unterschätzt nicht wie
viele leute das wirklich glauben und
welten nachts um drei passiert wirklich
was auf youtube gibt es immer einfach
sehr jungen zuschauer wahrscheinlich
zumindest ponys am ende spielte
aufgelöst ich höre ich wirklich jede
einzelne geschäftsteile in meinem kopf
stirbt gerade ab ich wäre es auch okay
irgendwann kommt von die stadtansichten
ausgemacht wenn du aufnimmt
top-leute okay leute die auch für beste
weibliche darstellerin im jahr 2000 mg n
a bonita es nicht zu glauben wir sind
noch nicht am ende ihres videos ich bin
heute hier die gute lösung nach wie vor
auf ich bin optimist ich glaube menschen
kommen nein wir könnte ich nicht leben
weil jemand das licht in der schweiz
immer ausgemacht hat man ohne es ist der
jüngste trend auf youtube seitdem ich
youtube kenne ich hab noch nie so was
hängen geblieben das gesehen 24 stunden
war nicht so schlimm waren ihnen war
längst im dach kopf glücklich jetzt will
ich erstmal das ende von mir sehen
[Musik]
110.000 abonnenten letzten 30 tage 4000
clubs am tag
ich glaube ich beende jetzt mein leben
ich habe gleich verständlich persönlich
nicht wie leute die jetzt in diesem
video aufgetaucht sind gegen ronnie und
rebecca einfach mal exemplare für die
ganze drei und nachts trend sehen jetzt
gerade aber bitte leute wenn ihr
irgendwo so eine ultra schlechte 3 und
nachts video sieht ein kommentierte mit
hashtags 14 uhr mittags einfach scheiße
einfach um den leuten mal zu zeigen das
was sie da gerade machen komplett hängen
einfach in diesem youtube zu zeigen dass
es da draußen noch menschen mit zwei
gelernt sein gibt und dass der homo
sapiens sack ist als jetzt vielleicht
noch nicht ganz voll
ich würde euch danken